is it true that you and Ben like
separated and then you know reconnected
in the pandemic yeah is that not every
person's fantasy that you will find your
way back how how did you do it I I feel
so lost I mean I it was a it was for us
we you know we got married very quickly
after meeting each other we we knew each
other six months got engaged we were
married within a year and then had Ella
the next year and I think for us like
life just you you especially in this
business and careers and you know a lot
of work and
you know family was always a priority
but I think Ben and I both sort of
started to grow in different directions
and when we made the decision to
separate it was not something we wanted
to talk publicly about it was not
something we
we took lightly either it was sort of
like we're both at sort of this impasse
of like let's figure out what's best
like what is best for us at this chapter
in our lives and this is going back
three or four years and that time apart
for each of us to sort of
get to know who we are like I think we
have these growth spurts even as adults
and I feel like we needed just some time
to figure that out so you know as the
and always stayed a family unit always
went continue to do things together
continue to see shows together
um birthday parties all of it all of it
um and so you know that when the
pandemic hit and we all had to sort of
figure out where we were gonna hunker
down we all ended up in the our house
together
two teenagers
um and you know we found this way back
of like we had so much time to talk we
had time to there's nothing there were
no other distractions so it was a really
special time for us for the family I
mean it was you know it was all done it
just happened organically
for us yeah all of us and our
perspective and our time and the way we
live our life I mean that is just so
wonderful and how are things now what's
the dynamic like with you and Ben I mean
I feel like when you've lived a lifetime
with someone and you know we have and
there's history and there were black
like we learned as we were going along
you know together and I think there's
just a a freedom in that there's a
freedom in the comfort of you know the
this this relationship and the
commitment and just also knowing that
and we also have to take care of
ourselves and does it make things better
it does it it I mean if you can do it
it's
I
love the Journey of life and every
single thing in it yeah I love it so
much that is your you are sharing that
with the world too I think you're giving
people the the permission to do that
like you are you just are like
appreciate the little stuff then the
entire Endeavor is validated thank you
Christine I'm not kidding
it's exactly it help me figure this
wonderful beautiful challenging life out
that is it and 25 years we've known each
other and I'm so happy that you have
this wonderful new Endeavor with your
podcast hey dude the 90s called
check it out Christine Taylor I Loved
You Then I love you now
[Music]
foreign